مشاهدينا منها طاي جنوب تركيا ينضم الينا
مفرد العربيه عمار الهندي عمار يعني مع
انتهاء اسبوع الزلزال الاول كيف هي الصوره
من هناك هل مازال الامل موجود بالعثور على
ناجين تحت الانقاض
على ما يبدو انك بمركز ايماء اليوم هو
اليوم الثامن
صحيح صحيح ولكن ساجيبك على موضوع الامل
نحن شهدنا قصه اليوم حينما جئنا ظهرا الى
هذا المركز وهو مركز لايواء السوريين
الذين يعني انهدمت بناياتهم ومنازلهم
وتدمرت جاؤوا الى هذا المركز يعني يتلقون
المساعده الاوليه واسعافات اوليه ثم ينقل
عبر حافلات الى مدن اخرى ولكن اليوم صباحا
كنا التقينا بطفل هنا ووالده واخوه اسمه
محمود وكانوا كان اثنين من اشقاؤه لا يزال
تحت الانقاض استخرجوا على قيد الحياه وكان
والده ناشد عبر شاشه الحدث ان يتم انتشال
او اخراج اطفاله من تحت الالقاء الانقاض
وبالفعل خرجوا احياء اليوم في هاتاي وكانت
فرحه كبيره رغم مرور ثمانيه ايام على
وجودهم هناك ونحن لازلنا ليال في مركز
الايواء هذا القصص تتجدد كلما جاء احد
منها تاي نستمع قصه جديده معاناه جديده
هذه السيده جاءت للتو من هاتاي وهي متعبه
ومريضه واود ليال سريعا ان نستمع الى
مشكلتها وما الذي تعاني منه الحمد لله على
السلامه اولا
يلا يسلمك حضرتك كنت وقت وقت الزلزال
بالبيت كنت بالبيت ووقعت على وجهي ضليت
بال جوع يعني لو راح الهزه لاحسنت امه
واطلع من البيت
ضليت بالغرفه
لا راحت الهزه احسنت زين من هالدرج كمان
هالدرجه كله
وقفنا تحت المطر طول الليل
بعدهم جينا الصبحيات على بيتنا
رجعنا يعني
اغراضي كله مي
وبركنه البيت البيت انهدم
طيب انت انت مريضه او ايش مالك انا مريضه
جايه لهوني
ابعتوني من سوريا من مستشفى مستشفى
المركزي يعني انت جئت من سوريا سكنتي في
انطاكيا حدث الزلزال جدي للعلاج يعني لا
لا لا هذا نصر العلاج بسوريا وحولوني لها
ونكمل علاجي ولما جئتي صار الزلزال
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
[موسيقى]
سرطان بالمبايض
بلا اكل ولا اشرب وناكل
اكلتا سلامتك الف سلامه
يعني انت الان تحتاجي لنقل الى المستشفى
مستشفى مختص بالسرطان
انه على شاشه العربيه وان شاء الله ويكون
صوتك وصل ونحن في مركز ايواء مركز حماه
هنا في انطاكيا في في هاتاي
سلامتك
سلامتك الف سلامه اكلت اليوم اكلتي شيء
الساحه وموزه
هذا استفرغتها
اعتذر ان كنت اطلت في الوقت ولكن يعني
استمع الى تفاصيل هذه القصه نعم هي قصه
طبعا يعني انسانيه ومحزنه جدا على امل
يعني ان يكون هناك ايادي بيضاء لمساعده
هذه السيده المسنه التي يعني لسوء حظه اتت
للعلاج وايضا ضرب زلزال في تركيا عمار
هناك العديد من القصص طبعا
المحزنه والمبكيه هناك نحن نعمل جاهدين
لنقل كله على الهواء بما انك تتحدث عن
يعني مراكز الايواء عن المساعدات عن كل
هذا الموضوع الحكومه التركيه كانت قد
اعلنت عن ان حوالي 96 الف عامل انقاذ تركي
واجنبي موجودين اليوم على الارض هل يعني
عمليات الانقاذ او من هم على الارض كافيين
حتى الساعه ام ان النقص ما زال كبير
انا التقي ابتعدت عن مناطق
الدمار وجئت هنا لاتفحص اوضاع النازحين
وتبين انها ماساه توازي ماساه البحث عن
الاشخاص تحت الانقاض لانه طبعا هنالك نقص
كبير في الفرق لانه الناس تاتي الى هنا
وتشتكي ان ان
افراد من عائلاتهم لا يزال تحت الانقاض
وانه ليس هنالك فرق انقاذ كافيه الانتشال
الناجين او جثامينهم تحت الانقاض وبالتالي
هنالك مشكله كبيره هنالك في مناطق الدمار
لا تزال العمليات جاريه هنا في المناطق
النزوح لهؤلاء
جدا هل هي قادره على استيعاب كل الذين
يعني تشردوا بعد هذا الزلزال العمليات
الطبيه او المساعده الطبيه اللازمه هل هم
قادرين على يعني اتمام لكل من يدخل الى
هذه المراكز
انا ساخبرك ليال هذا المركز مثلا متواجد
هنا في انطاكيا للسوريين لانه هنالك عدم
قدره على استيعاب اعداد كبيره في المراكز
التابعه
للسلطات التركيه والمخيمات التي اقامتها
اباد اللي هي مركز اداره الازمات والطوارئ
التركي هذا المركز منذ ثمانيه الايام سالت
كنا سالنا رئيس المركز استقبل الاف
الاشخاص هنالك حافلات طبعا هذا كله مجهود
من متبرعين من جمعيات خيريه بسيطه على
نفقاتهم يتم نقل هؤلاء الناس الى المدن
تركيا اخرى حسب طلبهم وكنا ايضا زرنا على
بعد 100 متر من هنا مخيم قيد الانشاء تقوم
به جمعيه خاصه جمعيه خيريه خاصه تركيا
يهيئ لاستقبال النازحين من مختلف الجنسيات
وليس حكرا على جنسيه معينه او على مواطن
وبالتالي هنالك نقص طبعا ذلك المخيم يتسع
الى اربعه الاف شخص ولكن الاعداد التي
كبيره جدا وهنالك مشكله اكبر من ذلك بان
الاشخاص الذين ياتون الى هنا السوريين
مثلا ويتم نقلهم الى مدن اخرى هناك حينما
يصل الى بورصه او مدن ثانيه لا يجدون من
يستقبلهم ليست هنالك خيام او مخيمات
لايوائهم وبالتالي هذه مشكله كبيره مشكله
المشكله الانسانيه والمساعدات من
المساعدات كنا التقينا فرق هنا شاب سعودي
ياتي يعني يتبرع على نفقته مع عشره شباب
اخرين جاؤوا من دول مختلفه هنا على عاتقهم
يقوموا بالتبرع وجلب المساعدات هنالك
عمليات تطوعيه كبيره ولكنها حتى هذه
اللحظه
على كل حال ساكمل معك يعني بالفترات
اللاحقه لنقل سوره
المراكز مراكز الايواء في المناطق التركيه
شكرا لك عمار هندي مفرد العربيه